Tommy I'll start with you there's such
hypocrisy here Hilary money from from
Sharia countries all the money weinstein
gave to liberals liberals ignoring the
Clintons as long as they have the right
politics they'll ignore all of Bill's
sins of groping fondling touching
kissing and in the case of Juanita
Broderick we know what she said so
there's such hypocrisy from them well of
course it is and I think it's important
for us to understand the left does not
Pro woman the left is anti-trump and
there's a big difference as evidenced by
their radio silence this week now of
course they come out they tweet their
disgust and Hillary said she was
appalled really Hillary were you really
appalled
we appalled by Bill - because you stayed
with them I don't believe any of this I
want Hillary Leslie to give back the
money that she took from Saudi Arabia
and all these countries that oppress
women many that killed gays and lesbians
and have persecuted Christians and Jews
will you join me in calling for her to
give back the money that she took from
those countries that bought her silence
you know it's interesting Shaun is
everybody on the right tells me Hillary
should not answer my question I could
already just remember that you lost no I
don't think she has to give back money
that was given to a campaign sure are
these countries because money although
it's horrific what happens to women in
Saudi Arabia there is progress with
women's arm on radio Judy the region
save money right to vote would you take
money from a country that tells women
how to dress women you know they can't
travel abroad that kills gays and
lesbians and you can't build a temple or
a church would you take money from those
people that's a yes or no but to take
money from Oman I'm on a witness stand I
can only say yes or no that's right we
just go down the country I couldn't take
money from France could I cause of the
burqa so I don't think it's fair to ask
that in that context oh yeah because
they would have women systematically
money from France you know I almost
sound like the Liberals here camera
Tommy because I'm saying I'm standing up
for women they're killing innocent
people because of their sexual
orientation and they're persecuting
people for religious reasons and I'm
saying that's blood
hillarie give it back where does tommy
larren Stan well I think that she should
give it back but I don't expect it I
don't expect much from Hillary at this
point I mean she's pedaling her books at
Costco talking about women's rights she
lectures us on a weekly basis about
misogyny and she gives us the definition
on stage time and time and time again
but then her spokesperson sends out a
tweet about Weinstein she doesn't give
the money back or she's gonna give to
charity or she's gonna do something with
it again Hillary he want to be out of
the spotlight the out of the spite Lee
if you want to be in the spotlight be in
the spotlight and announced people like
Harvey Weinstein we'd like to see you do
it but she won't do that because she's
Pro Hillary
she's Pro Democrat she's Pro whatever
lines her pockets and the rest of the
DNC as well yeah I can't believe you
won't say that they should get back that
money Leslie I'll give you one last
chance to redeem yourself she doesn't
need to give back money and why by the
way if she has to give back money to
this country Sean
in all fairness male or female she again
is she a hypocrite well wait a minute I
don't feel she's a hypocrite at all
absolutely not
absolutely not she she is not the
perpetrator was allegedly come on Harvey
Weinstein s beam me up Scottie